vamos a hacer algunos problemas con la
propiedad distributiva y lo que la
propiedad distributiva esencialmente nos
recuerda es que si tenemos digamos a x b
más c entonces lo que necesitamos es
multiplicar a cada uno de los sumandos
esto será a por b más aporte no sólo
será a por b y luego sumarle c sino hay
que multiplicar a ambos y ahora esto
todo tiene sentido no digamos que si
tuviera 5 x 3 + 7
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es bueno ya
que sabemos el resultado si decimos esto
es 5 por 10 que es 50
ahora bien usando la propiedad
distributiva usando la propiedad
distributiva lo que vamos a hacer es 5
por 3 que es 15 más 5 por 7 que son 35
ok y 15 más 35 es definitivamente 50 si
tú solo multiplicas 5 por 3 entonces
tienes 15
y ahora le suma 7 eso ya no fue 50 en
realidad sólo fueron 22 ok entonces de
cualquier forma vamos a aplicar este
tipo de problemas ha estado que tenemos
en la parte blanca con el ejercicio a
vamos a empezar y dice calcula un medio
de x menos -4 así que esto va a ser un
medio de x menos un medio de y menos
cuatro y ya hemos terminado vamos a
hacer ahora el ejercicio c
si tenemos 6 + x 57 bueno aquí realmente
no hay ninguna propiedad distributiva
así que sólo podemos quitar los
paréntesis y resolverlo esto será lo
mismo que 6 más x menos 5 + 7
ahora simplemente agrupamos los números
en este caso menos 5 762 y sumamos 6 y
eso nos da 8 más x muy bien ahora vamos
a hacer otro ejercicio digamos el
ejercicio y que es lo que dice tenemos 4
x m 7 menos 6 x 4 - m ok vamos a
utilizar la propiedad distributiva esto
será 4 m + 7 x 4 que es 28 y luego vamos
a hacer dos propiedades distributivas
primero dejamos como - y resolvemos esta
multiplicación que será 24 6 por 4 y
menos 6 m ahora hay que fijarnos
justamente que el menos va a realizar
una propiedad distributiva con lo que
está dentro del paréntesis por lo que
nos queda 4 m 28 menos por 24 por lo que
es menos 1 por 24
y es menos 24 y menos 1 x menos 6 m que
son más 6 m ahora agregamos los términos
que tienen m y esto nos da 10 m que es
46 m y después hacemos esta resta cuyo
resultado es 4
vámonos más abajo y vamos a utilizar la
propiedad distributiva para simplificar
estas fracciones ok
la primera que vamos a realizar es 8x +
12 sobre 4
así que esencialmente vamos a utilizar
la propiedad distributiva porque vamos a
tener que dividir entre 4 todo el
numerador lo cual significa que vamos a
tener que dividir cada uno de los
sumandos que están ahí o esto es lo
mismo que hacer una multiplicación de 1
entre 4 por 8 x + 12
ok y aquí es más claro cómo es que vamos
a utilizar la propiedad distributiva
esto será lo mismo que 8 x entre 4 + 12
entre 4 ok ahora 8 x entre 4 simplemente
es 2x y 12 entre 4 estrés esa es una
forma de hacerlo la otra forma de verlo
es multiplicando un cuarto por 8x que en
este caso es 2x y un cuarto por 12 que
es 3 en cualquier forma
obtenemos el mismo resultado vamos con
el ejercicio si tenemos 11 x + 12 sobre
es justamente como el ejercicio anterior
así que ponemos 11 medios por equis ok
es dividir el primero entre 2 más 12
entre 2 que es 6 ok vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio más el ejercicio y este parece
interesante miren tenemos el negativo de
6 z menos 2 entre 3 ok vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo que en los
ejercicios anteriores así que esto es
menos un tercio por 6 z menos 2 ok es
exactamente igual ahora esto es un
tercio negativo ok
así que vamos a jugar con los signos en
este caso utilizando la propiedad
distributiva tenemos que menos un tercio
por 6 z es menos 12 está
y menos un tercio por menos dos
simplemente es dos tercios y ahí lo
tienes ya está resuelto